You know, modern cars may still have a keyhole. But you don't have to use
it. As long as the key is nearby, it senses that you're an authorized driver.
So, how do I unlock this car? I just put my hand inside and
watch, it unlocks. Nice. Really, simple.
Easy. Turns on the interior lights too, so I can see. I can see
inside when it's dark. [NOISE]. Now suppose I leave,
and I want to lock the car. How do I
do it? Well you can't see, but there's a
little ridged area here. And if I touch it, watch.
It locks. Oh. But I left all the windows
open. And the sunroof open. Do I have to
open the car, and go in and manually shut
them? No, there's a secret way of shutting it. Secret,
hm. See, if I hold my finger here for a little while. The
windows shut. And the sunroof shuts. But
it is a secret. How do you ever learn it? Well, it's in the
manual. But who reads the manual? It's a big thick manual. People don't read
the manual. I know lots of people who own this car. Who are not
aware that they can shut all the windows and sunroof, without going back inside.
Nice feature. Hard to know about it.